[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler des
discours totalitaires la montée de
l'intolérance dans notre société dans le
brouhaha ambiant qu'il s'agisse de la
pensée éveillée ou voquise des réseaux
sociaux et de la vie politique il y a au
moins un sentiment consensuel au sein de
l'opinion publique la montée de
l'intolérance nous vivons ensemble sans
s'écouter ni s’entendre abreuver que
nous sommes par cette vague voquiste qui
prône une radicalisation des discours et
la revanche des minorités humiliées bien
souvent instrumentalisé et manipuler par
le complotisme et les fake news qui
inondent les réseaux sociaux il y a
aussi l'infantilisation des esprits en
retour de la perte d'influence du
discours politique et de la
déliquescence des idéologies de gauche
et de droite
nous avons là une situation extrêmement
préoccupante parce que sous prétexte
d'exhorter des sentiments généreux au
service de la revanche des humiliés des
offensés des Invisibles se déploient des
discours avisés totalitaire autrement
dit chacun d'entre nous risque de se
trouver assigné à des identités plus ou
moins
abstraite et également à des allégeances
communautariste
conflictuels il s'agit d'un
totalitarisme soft certes il ne s'agit
ni de fascisme ni de stalinisme mais il
s'agit d'un discours qui cherche à
rendre indistin les races les espèces
les gens les discours bref avec mes
invités nous allons chercher à
décortiquer cette intolérance je vous
les présente mes invités Rachel Kahn
vous êtes essayiste Jean-François
Brunstein vous êtes philosophe et
professeur des universités huberco
Duriez vous êtes journaliste directeur
du Télégramme et Gérard Miller vous êtes
à la fois un homme de média mais vous
êtes d'abord psychanalyste et essayer
[Musique]
alors commençons par le vaucisme
qu'est-ce qui est à l'origine de ce
vauclisme est-ce qu'on peut dire c'est
de la lâcheté une revanche sociale une
révolte un absolu égalitaire
Jean-François Bronstein il y a plusieurs
choses à l'origine à l'origine c'est
effectivement sa part d'une révolte
sociale tout à fait légitime autour des
questions de Reims ou autour des
questions de genre et autres mais très
vite ça s'estompe ça s'est transformé en
espèce de vision globale du monde une
nouvelle vision globale du monde c'est
pour ça que j'ai gardé le terme de wok
qui est quelquefois discuté ou autre
c'est un réveil comme il y a eu des
réveils religieux protestants et ce qui
est très étonnant c'est que les adeptes
de cette religion wok refuse absolument
toute discussion avec leurs adversaires
qui sont considérés comme le mal comme
représentant une autre vision du monde
tout à fait incompatible et lorsqu'il
est très étonnant et c'est qu'on voit on
voit cela depuis pas mal d'années
maintenant dans les universités
américaines mais aussi françaises il
n'est est possible d'échanger des
arguments avec les gens avec qui nous ne
sommes pas d'accord j'ai été très frappé
moins récemment de voir que deux de mes
collègues ont refusé d'inscrire en thèse
des étudiants brillantsissimes sous le
simple prétexte qu'il n'arriverait pas
au même conclusion que dans à la fin de
leur thèse ou en tout cas il faisait des
hypothèses différentes c'est quelque
chose que je n'avais jamais vu dans
toute ma carrière et on voit ici
qu'effet arrière dont vous êtes
professeur de philosophie à l'Assemblée
effectivement j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un
le comble du plaisir pour un université
c'est de diriger une thèse de quelqu'un
qui est brillant et qui n'est pas
d'accord avec nous or aujourd'hui ils ne
veulent beaucoup de mes collègues j'ai
des exemples ne veulent diriger que les
gens qui sont d'accord avec eux donc ils
veulent plus échanger d'arguments et
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire donc de ce point de vue
là je dirais que l'université a été un
peu en avance sur l'intolérance
généralisée dans les médias etc mais
c'est encore plus choquant parce que
c'était c'était j'en parle au passé
c'était l'endroit où l'on pouvait
échanger des arguments y compris des
arguments tout café excentrique et que
bon je suis un grand lecteur de Stuart
Mill qui expliquait donc de la liberté
que la liberté notamment universitaire
repose sur la possibilité d'avoir des
opinions même excentriques ce n'est plus
le cas et effectivement aujourd'hui il y
a une espèce de chape de plomb qui
s'abat parce que les opposants sont
considérés comme le mal et on va on va
rentrer dans le détail mais alors sur
cette chape de plomb je voudrais vous
faire préciser quelque chose selon
Michel Houellebecq notre grand romancier
toute mode venue des États-Unis finit
par submerger tôt ou tard l'Europe
occidentale mais certains pensent je
pense à les séistes Hélène piccroz block
rose pardon la ruine en revient aux
intellectuels français sous-entendus
Foucault bar placard etc à votre avis
qui a raison Gérard Miller c'est
français ou c'est américain ou est-ce
qu'il y a vaucisme français alors comme
vous m'avez déjà invité dans votre vous
savez que je suis un garçon extrêmement
poli et donc j'accepte votre
introduction que je trouve un exemple
même d'intolérance monsieur Brunstein à
côté professeur des universités il se
trouve que je le suis également que nous
n'avons manifestement pas la même
expérience et que
permettrait de sourire pour commencer
cette émission que vous avez introduite
sur un ton aussi grave de sourire de la
menace walkiste qui me semble une menace
bien faible par rapport à d'autres
menaces dont je pourrais vous faire la
liste monsieur Brunstein est allé
jusqu'à évoquer certains de ses
collègues universitaires comme lui on
les décrivant après que vous ayez parlé
des totalités on les décrivant
finalement comme des gens qui seraient
capables du pire bon moi j'ai un point
de vue tout à fait différent et c'est
certainement
Miller j'ai un point de vue tout à fait
différent je ne suis pas un porte-parole
du mouvement walk mais enfin je trouve
irrésistible de présenter le walking
comme un épouvantail à ce point
terrifiant permett moi de vous dire que
c'est un épouvantail pour moineau je
vois surtout je ne dis pas qu'il
n'existe pas des dérives que n'existe
pas des excès que n'existe pas de
l'intolérance existent tout ce que vous
voulez mais enfin dans cette société qui
subit tellement d'injustice et
d'intolérance et notamment celle de
l'extrême droite y compris maintenant de
la droite y compris du macronisme je
trouve amusant que l'on veuille
maintenant reprendre je cite à ce
moment-là les noms que vous avez évoqué
que ce soit Foucault que ce soit là
comme ce soit Deleuze que de les prendre
comme les responsables de je ne sais
quelle dérive totalitaire c'était des
gens profondément et personne n'a dit ça
Gérard Miller je n'ai pas du tout dit ça
au contraire c'est c'est les noms qu'on
cite après une introduction sur la
question que vous vous a posé n'est pas
celle-là c'est de savoir à votre avis si
c'est made in America ou si c'est un
vauclisme qui vient aussi de France vous
avez raison de dire que en grande partie
ce qu'on appelle le wauquise mais
américain et moi qui suis un ancien
anti impérialiste je ne pourrais pas
vous dire que je porte les États-Unis
au-delà du raisonnable dans mon cœur
même si j'ai beaucoup d'amis américains
et que j'apprécie un certain nombre de
choses du pays donc je pense que ce
qu'on appelle le walking c'est en effet
un phénomène américain et qu'on a voulu
englober dans le wokis puisqu'on cite
malgré tout en arrière-plan Foucault ou
d'autres qu'on a voulu englober toute
une série d'intellectuels qui ont
contribué je le regrette pour mon
collègue universitaire qui ne le voit
pas qui ont voulu au contraire un stylet
dans l'université une je dirais une
variété de recherche d'intelligence de
complexité enfin lire Foucault ça n'est
en rien mais il n'a jamais dit ça
vous verrez qu'effectivement j'explique
qu'il n'y a aucun rapport entre Foucault
des Rida Lacan et ses penseurs qui sont
des penseurs
identitaires les penseurs que vous citez
que j'ai autant lu que vous ce sont des
auteurs au contraire plein de
contradictions d'ironie de subtilité ce
sont pas des penseurs de l'identité
c'est des penseurs au contraire des
identités multiples Foucault parlaient
de jeux avec énorme de jeu des possibles
etc et moi je pense justement que
l'erreur ce serait de dire que cette ce
qui est ce que une sorte de religion a
quelque chose à voir avec Foucault des
Rida et lakan quiconque a lui Foucault
des Rida et Lacan c'est que ces années
énorme contre sens c'est un énorme
contre sens on les a cité monsieur
Brunstein donc ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai
cités je pense que je pense que je pense
que mon ami m'allait justement qu'on
discute de cette question là parce que
beaucoup de gens pensent que ce nous
sommes responsables de ça pas du tout ce
sont des auteurs beaucoup plus subtiles
que ce qui nous revient les États-Unis
sur le fond du vaucisme est-ce qu'il dit
il y a une notion de l'acheter dedans
est-ce qu'il y a une notion d'éveil
est-ce qu'il y a une notion
d'intolérance j'espère ne pas choquer
les participants de ce débat en disant
que je reste sur un certain nombre de
plans les ninistes et Lénine disait que
très souvent on tord la barre dans
l'autre sens il y a aucun doute que ce
qui est en jeu du côté de vous appelez
le wokis c'est d'avoir tordu la barre
dans l'autre sens d'où des excès d'où
des folles d'un gris même absolument
mais je suis sensible étant toujours
contestataire moi-même au fait que ce
qui avait d'abord dans le vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs c'était effectivement la
révolte des minorités et toute une série
de sentiment d'injustice que je ne peux
pas condamner donc oui on a tordu la
barre dans l'autre sens et en même temps
ne nous empressons pas de faire
l'inverse parce qu'il y a des très
bonnes choses on va avoir quand même la
vie de Rachel Kahn et du Bercu Durier
alors sur à ce niveau du débat américain
ou français le vauclisme mais qu'est-ce
que ça représente pour vous
écoute-moi ça représente déjà j'aime
bien comment vous prononcer le mot
wauquisme parce que tout le monde dit
avec le W donc c'est intéressant vous
l'avez franchisé un petit peu vous avez
mis un V leokisme moi je préfère parler
de
des victimes au crack en fait en France
et en fait pour avoir vécu justement ces
questions évidemment des minorités parce
que femme parce que à fruits dit je
pourrais résumer
j'ai vécu ces questions là et les
batailles pour l'égalité dans dans ma
chair et en fait j'ai vécu finalement
l'intolérance de l'intérieur et c'est ça
mon problème avec ces victimesocrates je
me refuse à dire ce mot walk parce que
ça ne parle pas en fait lorsqu'on dit
wok pas tout à fait sauf si on a lu
votre dictionnaire mais ça nous en tant
que Français on comprend pas vous vous
parlez à d'intolérance à l'intérieur de
ces minorités je vous ai bien une parole
officielle sur la question sur qui en
fait si vous n'avez pas le langage de
votre votre peau c'est un problème et
vous êtes un traître donc c'est ça mon
sujet c'est-à-dire que donc vous vous le
vivez peut-être vous de l'extérieur mais
à l'intérieur on est quand même en
France avec cette liberté d'expression
cette démocratie cette nécessité de
dialoguer avec tout le monde
voilà c'est à dire que d'être en
victimes aussi permanente ce serait de
vous dire mon cher ami pourquoi vous
m'avez pas donné la parole en premier et
pourquoi mon temps n'est pas décuplé par
rapport à tous vos invités j'aurais de
vous la donner mais je vais poursuivre
avec Hubert Coudurier à ce niveau du
débat il y a quand même une précision à
apporter ce vaucisme à l'université dont
a parlé Jean-François Brunstein et qui a
contesté en partie Gérard Miller mais
que a retrouvé
Rachel Kahn dans les minorités ce
vaucisme à l'intérieur des réseaux
sociaux ce vaucisme au sein des partis
politiques et même dans certains médias
est-ce que pour vous c'est le même
mouvement où ça en tant que journaliste
et en observateur de la vie sociale
comme la vie politique est-ce que vous
considérez que c'est
la même déviation du langage si je peux
vous faites bien de rappeler je suis un
journaliste je suis pas un penseur donc
ça fait une quarantaine d'années que je
suis la vie politique et sociétale dans
ce pays et je vois les évolutions donc
effectivement on parle depuis un certain
temps d'une américanisation de la vie
politique française de la vie française
avec en même temps cette limite c'est
que comme le disait un ancien Président
on prend tous les défauts des États-Unis
mais pas forcément leur qualité en terme
d'énergie de créativité etc ensuite je
pense qu'il y a une révolution globale
qui passe par les médias par les réseaux
sociaux et qui est malgré tout une forme
de démocratisation aujourd'hui
l'autorité a perdu
son essence traditionnelle tout le monde
est mis un peu sur le même niveau là
aussi c'est un ancien président qui
parle il dit aujourd'hui tout le monde
habilité à parler au même niveau et
évidemment tout le monde n'est pas
capable de penser la complexité de la
même manière enfin le workisme est
devenu en France espèce de mot attrape
tout qui s'applique partout on parle de
Walking business dans mon dans ma région
par exemple la Bretagne ni les vilaine
vous avez un projet d'implantation d'une
usine Bridor qui devrait créer 500
emplois là-dessus les mouvements
écologistes aussi opposent et ce projet
ça fait déjà 5 ans que il n'arrive pas à
être mis en oeuvre et il faudra
peut-être encore cinq ans pour qu'ils
puissent être appliqués or en réalité
vous avez beaucoup de militants
d'extrême gauche qui ne sont pas de ce
de cette ville de Liffré ou le projet
pourrait être impliqué qui sont à la
manœuvre et qui s'expriment parce qu'ils
sont organisés parce qu'ils savent
maîtriser la communication et en face
vous avez des intérêts industriels
économiques qui eux sont dans une
prudence qui confine parfois vous avez à
la lâcheté parce que dans le fond cette
dictature des minorités qui s'expriment
et qui quelque part a aussi quelque
chose de très démocratique est-ce que la
majorité est capable aussi de s'y
opposer de faire prévaloir de temps en
temps des arguments de bon sens qu'il
s'agisse du genre de l'économie de
l'écologie non on est dans des dans des
dans un nom des bas parce que souvent
ceux qui pourraient apporter des
éléments de complexification ou tout
simplement de bon sens n'ose pas
s'exprimer c'est là où à mon avis il y a
une forme de l'acheter bien alors je
voudrais poursuivre avec un point
particulier
pensez le vauclisme comme une nouvelle
religion c'est ce que vous faites
Jean-François Brunstein est-ce que c'est
pas antinomique de notre laïcité
républicaine qui s'est construite
justement par émancipation à l'égard de
la religion qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cela je pense que c'est effectivement
antinomique de la République de
l'universalisme républicain et bien des
égards notamment ce que disait rachelcan
était tout à fait exact c'est que le
walkis veut nous enfermer dans des
identités communautaires de départ
l'obsession la race ils en viennent à
regretter qu'on ne parle pas assez de
race en France qui est quand même plutôt
une bonne chose à mon avis et plus plus
largement ce qui a et qui fait que je
parle de religion c'est qu'il y a une
critique très radicale chez ces auteurs
de l'idée même de sciences l'idée de
connaissances objective on ne peut pas
sortir du savoir de tel dominer versus
tel Haute-Savoie et donc en même temps
qu'un refus de l'universalisme je dirais
politique il y a un refus de la
recherche de la vérité objective et ce
qui est très étonnant ce qu'on voit en
lisant les écrits de ces auteurs que je
persiste à appeler wok parce que je vous
dis il y a un éveil il voit pas la même
chose que nous il voit un autre monde
que nous et on ne peut pas discuter avec
eux pour tous ces autos il y a une
critique très délibérée des lumières
c'est à dire de l'universalisme l'idée
d'homme abstrait même si évidemment je
dis pas que l'universalisme ça marche
c'est un idéal il y a une critique
effectivement de l'idée d'individus il
ne faut plus qu'on puisse être un un
individu qui se construit des
identifications multiples c'est ça qui
est insupportable pour vous comme pour
moi pour diverses raisons on peut
effectivement être plusieurs choses à la
fois et on change d'identité du jour au
lendemain et plusieurs fois dans la
journée et donc il y a cette critique là
il y a même une critique aussi de la
connaissance des lumières avec un éloge
du préjugé des savoirs indigènes etc et
c'est pour ça qu'il me semble que c'est
une critique des lumières donc je
critique pas ça d'un point de vue
réactionnaire ou conservateur puisque au
contraire je me moque de ces auteurs qui
retrouvent Bonal de Maistre et les
grands penseurs contre révolutionnaires
donc moi je pense que c'est
effectivement en ce sens c'est une
doctrine contre l'émancipation
ça trouve grâce auprès de vous Gérard
Miller que ce vauclisme et réactionnaire
parce qu'il fait retour à la religion
est-ce que vous me permettrez de dire
quand on cite Bonal ou d'autres on peut
citer plus près de nous encore des des
réactionnaires du 20e siècle permettrait
de dire qu'il y a des gens qui
officiellement si je puis dire se
réclame de ces gens-là du côté de
l'extrême droite zemmouriène et autres
donc ça m'amuse que on fasse des
correspondances de ce genre là où vous
avez peut-être raison c'est qu'en effet
il faut à chaque fois rappeler que nous
sommes les enfants des lumières que
notre République est
héritière de la Révolution française et
de ce qui a eu tout autour avant et
après ça d'accord mais est-ce que vous
ne voyez pas une chose simple quand par
exemple on dit c'est une très bonne
chose de ne pas parler de race si
possible d'en parlons pas c'est très
exact mais en même temps ça n'est pas
pour ça que ceux qui ont par exemple la
peau noire ou qui sont arabes n'a pas
dans notre société un certain nombre de
difficultés très particulières même si
on ne parle pas de race donc ce que je
vois quand j'entends Rachel pour me
tourner vers elle évoquer ce terme que
je ne connaissais pas bien de victimes
je le trouve terrible parce que il
évoque le fait qu'il y aurait des pseudo
victimes que ce serait un plaisir en
quelque sorte de se décrire comme
victime je vais vous donner la parole
démocrate moi je trouve si vous voulez
que ceux qui ont souffert à travers
l'histoire est relativement récente ont
en quelque sorte un petit temps pendant
lesquels ils peuvent éventuellement même
déconner vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est à dire que quand on voit puisqu'on
parle des États-Unis comment les Noirs
étaient traités il y a quand même pas si
longtemps quand j'étais moi adolescent
il y avait encore des Noirs qui ne
pouvaient pas s'installer dans les bus
donc quand on voit cette histoire longue
ignoble à l'égarder noir je me dis que
les Noirs américains ils ont un peu de
temps un peu de temps avant qu'on leur
fasse la leçon je suis évidemment
d'accord avec vous lorsque vous désignez
des excès mais moi j'ai connu y compris
en mai 68 donc bien dans le walkies j'ai
connu la naissance du MLF où les femmes
par exemple nous disaient lorsqu'on
rentrait dans une pièce veuillez sortir
on veut parler entre nous et on ne
considérait pas que c'était indigne j'ai
connu des moments où au moment où a été
créé le Front d'action révolutionnaire
homosexuel on nous disait finalement il
faut d'abord laisser les homos entre
parlé donc je sais pas comment vous dire
vous avez raison sur le fait que on
pourrait prendre un ça donc d'éléments
et dire c'est insupportable nous nous
sommes pour l'universalisme pour l'homme
ce qui était étonnant laissez un tout
petit peu les minorités donc c'est juste
que je veux dire laissez les minorités y
compris parfois être un peu excessif
parce qu'elles ont aussi le droit de
l'être moral en tant que minorité je
peux répondre
parce que c'est ça tout le tout le jeu
c'est ça qui est très intéressant parce
que nous sommes en France et que nous
n'avons pas la même histoire que les
États-Unis c'est ça le et moi j'ai été
élevé par évidemment par un père qui a
connu la décolonisation je parlerai pas
de ma mère après la joie mais justement
de ce père qui m'a transmis le fait que
nous en tant français notre origine
c'était la bibliothèque par exemple et
qu'elle nous était ouverte et que c'est
vrai que lorsque Joséphine Baker
arrivait en France et qu'elle a un homme
qui lui sourit un homme blanc qui lui
sourit elle se dit mais c'est pas
possible je n'ai jamais vécu ça de ma
vie et effectivement je vous rejoins
c'est le fait que pour lutter contre les
illuminés qui justement nous empêchent
de parler parce que ma couleur de peau
m'empêche de dire que je suis
universaliste ou humaniste ou que j'aime
la République la meilleure manière de
lutter c'est d'être de mettre en oeuvre
l'égalité de se battre contre
couleur de peau vous empêche
en quoi vous le savez mais pourquoi la
sortie de Racer c'était ça c'était
c'était à la sortie de mon bouquin
c'était par rapport à ce que je disais
ces mots qui vous séparent de je refuse
qu'on me désigne en tant que femme
racisées par exemple je refuse ce mot et
là ça veut dire vraiment pourquoi je
parle de c'est que ce mot vous enferme
depuis votre naissance depuis votre
essence et jusqu'à la fin de votre vie
vous serez racisé et vous mourrez racisé
et pour moi c'est terrible c'est
l'inverse de cette émancipation et c'est
surtout l'inverse de la liberté la
liberté de penser la liberté de faire
des choses la liberté d'être demain je
sais pas un homme blanc sur scène la
liberté d'écrire voilà merci
[Musique]
alors je vais revenir à ce côté
réactionnaire vous avez vu cette
citation de Roland Bart
pourquoi à votre avis ce retour au
bonheur de l'identité et cet exaltation
du semblable limitée à des communautés
d'esprit ou de pratiques est-ce que vous
acceptez cette chose-là Gérard Miller
mais je crois que c'est un mauvais débat
que d'opposer l'identité et l'universel
je vais prendre puisque rachel a parlé
de son cas je vais prendre le mien je
suis enfant de juifs polonais arrivé
avant guerre dans ce pays et
un jour j'ai découvert dans un livre où
on parlait de mon frère et de moi un
livre sur la psychanalyse ont marqué
Gérard Miller et Jacques Alain Miller
fils d'immigrer polonais je me suis dit
mais de qui parle-t-il je n'avais jamais
pensé que j'étais fils d'immigré je vous
assure vous allez absurde j'étais
tellement français mais en même temps je
sais que le tellement français que je
suis depuis toujours c'est toujours
penser aussi comme juif même si je ne
suis pas croyant et pratiquant et je
n'ai jamais vu d'opposition dans tous
les Juifs qui m'entouraient de cette
génération là et de la génération de mes
parents faire une contradiction entre le
fait d'être profondément dans l'histoire
juive et en même temps d'être
incroyablement français et je trouve
toujours désagréable qu'on dise à un
certain nombre de gens qui ont des
origines comme on dit que ce soit des
origines géographiques des religieuses
ou autres de leur dire faites un choix
non on est d'autant plus français qu'on
sait aussi qui est justement vous êtes
en train de dire vous êtes en train de
dire ce que je défends depuis le début
de cette émission c'est-à-dire que vous
pouvez être juif et universalisme ce qui
n'est pas le cas du mouvement vogue
c'est le contraire justement puisque
c'est une exaltation d'une identité
particulière qui exclut de l'universel
c'est tout le problème c'est quand on
nie l'identité de l'autre il a tendance
peut-être à se replier sur cette
identité c'est aussi parce qu'on a
maltraité un certain nombre de gens
qu'ils soient noir qui soit arabe qui
soit musulman qui soit juifs à d'autres
moments de l'histoire ou même encore
aujourd'hui évidemment c'est aussi pour
ça que du coup il y a ce repli que vous
appelez communautaire mais si vous
voulez moi quand je suis comme vous prof
parfois j'avais des étudiants
par exemple d'origine algérienne qui me
disait les Français et je hurlais à ce
moment leur dire mais vous êtes français
arrêtez de dire les Français mais
lorsque j'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir une
fille puisque j'ai cinq enfants une
fille qui s'est mariée à un moment donné
avec un juif très religieux français
tout ce qui a plus il disait aussi les
Français il était juif et il disait les
Français je vous dis mais arrête tu es
français donc ne sous-estimez pas le
fait que dans un certain nombre de cas
les gens ont tendance à se replier sur
leur communauté comme on dit lorsqu'ils
se sentent isolé du droit uniquement je
vais poser la question à uber coupurier
moi comme journaliste politique pendant
de très nombreuses années aujourd'hui je
m'occupe beaucoup plus de
l'international
dans les années 80 90 comme journaliste
politique des hommes politiques
m'appelaient dans un quotidien national
et me parler des juifs comme de la
communauté donc vous voyez qu'il y avait
cette spécification c'est spécificité
qui était accordée donc le
communautarisme existe aussi et il est
même utilisé par les politiques
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez huberto
Duriez je vous conseille un très joli
film de James Grey je vous parlais des
Juifs qui qui racontent finalement son
enfant dans la communauté juive
ukrainienne de New York le
film s'appelle Armageddon time ça veut
dire qu'en fait à l'époque il perçoivent
l'élection de Ronald Reagan comme
l'Armageddon c'est-à-dire un homme qui
va bouleverser la planète et peut-être
même la mettre en danger et on peut pas
resituer ce débat du wauquisme sans
comprendre l'évolution du monde ça
globalisation les problèmes climatiques
actuels et les angoisses que ça suscite
notamment chez les jeunes parce tout ce
qu'on dit finalement l'écologie et la
tendance à devenir violente mais pour
beaucoup de jeunes il faut qu'elle soit
violentes si elles veulent être entendue
puisque jusqu'à présent au cours des
décennies passées ils n'ont pas été
entendus et finalement aucun effort n'a
été fait et donc je crois qu'il faut
aussi prendre en compte la nostalgie du
gauchisme de l'extrême gauche qui voit
que aujourd'hui ils en train de perdre
la main par rapport à des illusions par
rapport à une mythologie de voir la
progression des idées effectivement
conservatrices ou d'extrême droite selon
que comment vous les appelez dans le
monde de voir finalement ce combat
incertain entre les Trump Biden
bolzonaro Lula etc et il y a quelque
chose qui se joue en ce moment et qui
suscite beaucoup d'angoisse et avec je
pense que le mouvement le workisme c'est
un mouvement dans les deux sens qui
fonctionne moi je vois des amis de
certains de communauté des Arabes qui
effectivement ont terriblement envie
d'être français mais qui en même temps
parfois en doute et se repli sur
eux-mêmes je veux dire c'est aussi
l'expression de nos contradictions
actuelles à un moment donné justement
alors Rachel kan puisque on est en train
de mondialiser le débat est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a un lien entre ces
replis communautaires c'est repli
identitaires et au niveau des États une
montée du populisme de l'extrême droite
on l'a vu avec train aux États-Unis on
l'a vu en Israël avec ceux qui
accompagnent Benjamin Netanyahou on l'a
vu avec bolsonaro au Brésil est-ce que
vous voyez une diagonale entre les deux
de toute façon c'est la démocratie qui a
mal c'est la démocratie qui est malade
c'est-à-dire que tous les régimes que
vous évoquez là les situations où le
populisme est notamment l'extrême droite
arrive au pouvoir c'est que c'est la
démocratie qui est entachée et surtout
enfin on a un gros problème sur
l'autorité nos fondamentaux et comme une
forme de perte de repères et je crois
que lorsque moi je suis pas une obsédée
du wauquisme mais ces questions là
d'identité le fait de vraiment
s'auto convaincre et surtout de raviver
finalement des plaies du passé parce
qu'en fait on souffre tous c'est quand
même quelque chose qui qui
relate en fait de notre perte de repères
je crois et aussi probablement du fait
que on est dans des temps instantanés où
la connaissance la connaissance la
création n'est plus mise au centre on
parle bien évidemment très souvent face
aux populismes de guerre culturelle de
bataille culturelles en mettant pas les
artistes au centre et je pense que là
pour le coup les artistes seraient très
prescripteur
très fédérateur et très réparateur de de
cette de ces questions mondiales qui qui
nous écorce profondément dans nos
humanités alors je voudrais permuter vos
rôles vous êtes philosophe Jean-François
branstein vous êtes psychanalyse Gérard
Miller je voudrais inverser minéraux
faire que vous vous soyez psychanalyste
et lui philosophe vous assignez les gens
alors attendez je voudrais savoir c'est
quand même intéressant que le débat se
débat sur le vauclisme sur le les
identités etc on a été amené à ce que
les uns les autres ils évoquent leur
identité que ce soit juif noir qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez je trouve que c'est
une catastrophe pour ma part je pense
que les identités ont les uns mais on
n'a pas besoin de toujours les mettre en
avant d'une certaine manière je pense
que ce qui est très étonnant de voir
c'est qu'aux États-Unis les gens qui
sont les plus critiques de ces questions
ou autre ce sont souvent des
intellectuels noirs Thomas chatterton
Williams Glenn etc John McCarter parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas être juste définis
par leur caractère de victime nous
sommes toutes sortes de choses nous
sommes créateurs nous sommes linguistes
dans leur cas nous sommes philosophes
etc et moi je trouve ça très très
réducteur alors en même temps je
comprends le fait qu'effectivement il y
a c'est une période de
de mort si je puis dire des idéologies
donc ça donne un sens effectivement je
ne je ne nie pas l'enthousiasme le le la
franchi la réalité de ces idées chez les
jeunes qui effectivement sont
enthousiasme pour cela comme pour le
climat et cetera mais je dirais que
c'est un peu par défaut et moi je trouve
que essayer de fabriquer si je puis dire
des identités dont on a réussi tous plus
ou moins tous sur ce plateau plus ou
moins se défaire c'est une énorme
régression je trouve pas que c'est une
bonne idée du tout ça veut pas dire
qu'effectivement je la lutte anti
raciste c'est quelque chose mais si on
si on s'obsède sur la race au nom de la
lutte antiracisme c'est le contraire la
lutte contre les discriminations de
genre oui mais si on est obsédé par
cette question du genre et qu'on efface
la biologie etc c'est pas non plus une
bonne idée donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement il y a un point de
départ sympathique et logique et
acceptable mais ça c'est totalement
contre-productif c'est-à-dire qu'on en
arrive effectivement à nous poser la
question as-tu dit ça parce que tu es
juif ou parce que tu es juif une page
vive mais les autres grands-parents sont
pas juifs donc c'est pour ça que tu es
pour la diversité mais c'est absurde
c'est-à-dire que je pense que c'est une
énorme régression je pense à vous genre
Miller
écoutez quand vous ne pouvez pas par
exemple facilement obtenir un
appartement à louer parce que vous êtes
arabe vous savez que c'est quand même
quelque chose qui se pose tout le temps
pour ceux qui sont arabes dans notre
pays ils ont beaucoup plus de mal que
vous ou moi à trouver un appartement
s'ils en cherchent vous ne pouvez pas
reprocher à cela à celui-là ou à
celle-là vous pouvez pas se reprocher de
sentir qui en effet un problème
particulier avec son identité c'est
comme si on disait à des ouvriers qui
sont en grève pour leur salaire mais mon
vieux vous n'êtes pas qu'un salarié
exploité vous êtes plein d'autres choses
vous êtes obsédé par votre salaire mon
vieux non il faut accepter même si je
suis d'accord je vois bien quel est
votre idée de fond il faut accepter que
les exploités il faut accepter que ceux
qui sont discriminés d'une façon d'une
autre ce qui est terrible c'est les faux
discriminer s'il y en a mais dans
l'ensemble j'ai quand même le sentiment
que dans ce pays les gens qui protestent
les gens qui se sentent victimes le sont
réellement je suis d'accord avec vous
ils ne sont pas que ça et c'est très
important qu'ils aient le sentiment
qu'ils sont bien d'autres choses mais ne
leur reprochez pas quelque chose je
dirais pas de leur fait de ce point de
vue là je dirais que aucun jeune dans
notre pays n'arrive à louer
d'appartement en ce moment parce que
c'est beaucoup trop cher il faut aussi
tenir compte de ça c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a un grave problème et aucun évidemment
d'acheter quelque chose comme vous
remarquez les jeunes majoritairement
votés pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon quand ils
ont voté donc c'est bien qu'il y a aussi
une identité jeune possibilité
alors parce que lorsque on
énonce certaines choses par rapport au
wokismes et par rapport et je continue
de le dire à cette victimocratie je
pense que cette victimocratie fait mal
au réel victimes c'est-à-dire que le
fait de parler du wokisme souvent on
vous dit ah oui tu parles du wauquisme
etc donc tu es d'extrême droite et
surtout tu es dans un déni de la réalité
mais non c'est très précisément parce
que je refuse que les jeunes soient dans
des
des identités prison des identités qui
ne leur permettent pas lorsqu'ils ont
après leurs études 25 ans 30 ans 40 ans
de se révéler jusqu'à leur mort que je
me battrai contre ces choses qui sont
alors nous ne sommes pas dans des
régimes totalitaires mais ça fait partie
du langage totalitaire c'est à dire que
ça ne permet pas l'émancipation et pour
des gens qui se disent qui luttent
contre les discriminations qui se
rappellent à la mémoire de l'esclavage
de l'esclavagisme ou de l'esclavage les
esclaves voulaient avoir un nom et un
prénom les esclaves voulaient ne pas
être d'accord entre eux donc ce n'est
pas parce qu'on a la même couleur de
peau qu'on a qu'on a l'obligation d'être
d'accord entre nous parce que là c'est
vraiment raciste de dire ça les noirs
doivent penser tous la même chose par
exemple ces catastrophique et c'est pour
ça que je me bats bec et ongles pour la
liberté de tous et surtout contre les
discriminations et notamment pour les
jeunes d'avoir tous un logement
on a connu la crise des missiles de Cuba
nous parle aujourd'hui du danger
nucléaire avec l'Ukraine on a connu la
guerre du Vietnam avec cette formidable
mobilisation des jeunes aux États-Unis
et dans le monde et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans une société
où les gens ont peur ou en tout cas
expriment un peu trop leur peur et
l'absence d'espoir de changement
d'évolution avec un pouvoir politique
qui navigue au plus près regardez le
chef de l'État aujourd'hui
on sussure même qui serait déprimé parce
que je ne sais pas je ne crois pas mais
en tout cas qu'il cherche un cap et
qu'il est capable finalement sur des
sujets comme les migrations avec ce
bateau à Marseille mais d'autres sujets
sur l'Algérie de changer de cap en
permanence qui n'est pas franchement
rassurant donc aujourd'hui on paye aussi
le prix de la transparence et de la
démocratisation du savoir de la
massification de l'enseignement par
rapport à des réponses économiques qui
sont plus compliquées et pour lesquelles
on ne peut on ne pourra changer
qu'en développant
et la technologie et c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui est un problème de fond
c'est de donner de l'espoir à notre
société tout à fait mais alors il y a
quand même sur ces minorités ou
finalement il y a pas des accords mais
quand même des plus que des dissonances
entre vous il y a un point prenant par
exemple le féminisme
MiTo a libéré la parole des femmes c'est
contestable personne de conteste ça mais
il y a aussi un ultra féminisme qui
existe Sandrine Rousseau propose je la
cite de flamber le patriarcat avec
enthousiasme
ces attitudes se développent au niveau
de certaines pensées minoritaires
comment vous expliquer Rachel Kahn que
finalement
l'arbitraire se confond avec la liberté
et donc l'arbitrage devient l'arbitraire
aujourd'hui vous parlez de
d'un cas spécifique parce que la
question de l'égalité des droits la
question de l'égalité des droits des
femmes notamment c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il nous faut jamais rien lâcher
ensuite la problématique c'est d'avoir
une parole peut-être qui fasse le buzz
et alors peut-être je vais pas du tout
répondre à votre question mais avec les
réseaux sociaux avec les émissions qui
sont transmis sur les réseaux sociaux il
y a quand même quelque chose où la
parole n'est plus sacré dans un sens où
elle fait progresser une pensée mais
elle est plus là vous avez retenu cette
petite phrase par exemple elle est plus
là pour créer un buzz et là pour moi on
est plus dans une démarche de
un peu de je vois Donald Trump là qui
est juste là-bas un peu de trumpisation
de la politique plus que de parler du
féminisme au fond donc là les choses
s'entremêlent donc je ne réponds pas à
votre question mais je voulais tout de
même que c'est une trumpisation c'est
une tropique c'est une Trump le fait
d'avoir
un quart d'heure de notoriété dans sa
vie on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une obsession aujourd'hui
il faut trouver des petites phrases pour
apparaître en politique on le sait très
bien donc si c'est le cas soit de
l'environnement soit du féminisme soit
de l'économie soit il y a toujours cette
petite phrase qui a été voilà
effectivement expérimenté via les
réseaux sociaux et Donald Trump où il y
a c'est ce buzz ou ses bad buzz et ça
fait pas avancer la question de
l'égalité des droits à mon sens
[Musique]
en politique la mode est au ni droite ni
gauche et on a un développement des
extrêmes en tout cas dans un éventail
politique qui se développe
sur les extrémités est-ce qu'à votre
avis Gérard Miller c'est la fin des
idéologies ou finalement ça n'est qu'une
mode la mode aujourd'hui si tentait
qu'on peut utiliser ce terme la mode est
à la droite extrême ça il y a aucun
doute qu'un mauvais vent souffle sur
notre pays et c'est pour ça que je
trouve qu'on fait du wauquisme un
épouvantail facile parce que quand vous
citez Sandrine Rousseau par chance vous
n'avez pas essayé de nous faire trop
peur avec elle moi je la trouve tout à
fait formidable et tout à fait utile à
la démocratie même si justement on veut
combattre tel ou tel de ses propositions
moi je vous dirais que me fait
infiniment plus peur monsieur Darmanin
que je trouve justement dans le courant
mainstream aujourd'hui de la
droitisation de ce pays donc voyez ce
qui est gênant c'est que je sais bien
qu'on peut pas courir toujours tous les
lièvres à la fois mais que le wokisme
avec tous ces excès avec tous ces tout
ce que vous voulez c'est tellement
mineur un vrai danger que vous évoquez
c'est à dire la droiteisation extrême de
gens vous pouvez interpeller Darmanin et
Sandrine Rousseau je pourrais mais
pourquoi vous voulez
je préfère interpeller celui qui me
semblait légèrement plus dangereux mais
je veux dire par là que ce qui est
gênant dans les débats sur le workisme
et je ne parle pas de vous j'ai pas lu
votre livre et je ne parle pas de vous
personnellement ce qui est gênant c'est
qu'on voit bien en effet pourquoi
l'extrême droite s'en étant paré je dis
pas que ça délégitime le sujet l'extrême
droite s'en est emparée parce que ça lui
permet à l'extrême droite de ne pas
cibler toute une série d'autres dangers
majeurs donc c'est c'est ce sens là que
je trouve que c'est un ennemi facile le
walkisme
par exemple Sandrine Rousseau
lorsqu'elle explique bon qu'elle préfère
les sorcières au constructeur de prière
ou lorsqu'elle dit que la catastrophe a
commencé avec des cartes et le
rationalisme et que lorsque l'inné
Buffon classé la nature ils l'ont
hiérarchisé donc ils ont pris le pouvoir
sur la nature ça me semble des
propositions un petit peu alors c'est
amusant d'une certaine manière j'aime
bien les choses comme ça mais c'est pour
faire du buzz effectivement et moi je
pense qu'effectivement cette histoire
les réseaux sociaux est un vrai problème
parce que l'idée c'est effectivement de
qui est des groupes qui se de followers
qui se poursuivent les uns les autres ça
a des conséquences sur les questions du
genre mais ça aussi des conséquences sur
la question de Me Too c'est-à-dire que
effectivement désormais l'idée c'est que
le jugement se fait sous la loi de la
meute effectivement et non pas dans le
dans un tribunal avec des procédures
contradictoires etc alors moi de ce
point de vue là il y a un auteur
américain que j'aime beaucoup c'est
britishodelice qui explique que il
résume les woks mais bon mettez ce que
vous voulez derrière c'est la se
débarrasser de l'individu je crois qu'il
y a vraiment une volonté de se
débarrasser de l'individu de ne plus
penser par soi-même alors que Sandrine
Rousseau dis ce qu'elle veut moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord je vous dis je suis
même très favorable aux absurdités dites
par des universitaires si je puis dire
parce que ça permet de le débat mais
reprendre ça comme parole d'évangile si
je peux me permettre ça me semble
vraiment très compliqué une prof
d'économie qui dit Descartes c'est le
rationalisme donc c'est le mal je veux
dire je suis un peu oui Hubert coupurier
et donc elle est pas très dangereuse
alors maintenant il est ministre de
l'Intérieur il a beaucoup de pouvoir on
peut considérer que c'est un sous
Sarkozy il fait face à des problèmes
complexes il y a une problématique de
l'autorité et on verra bien si au final
on crédite le chef de l'État et ceux qui
voudront se revendiquer pour la
présidence d'avoir restauré une forme de
d'autorité régalienne ou pas mais le
fond du problème aujourd'hui c'est il
est pas là c'est c'est comment comment
est-ce qu'on gère la société actuelle
comment est-ce qu'on lui donne une
cohérence comment est-ce qu'on la régule
est-ce que c'est l'optique social des
modes traditionnels sans vouloir
incarner aujourd'hui le chef de l'État
où est-ce que c'est effectivement un
retour ou un conservatisme dur qui n'a
d'ailleurs jamais vraiment existé en
France parce que la révolution
conservatrice on n'a jamais vécu en
France oh et moi je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous pour dire que
les paroles vous avez incité Sandrine
Rousseau ça n'est que du buzz je parte
pas votre point de vue parce que prenons
ce que veulent dire Sandrine Rousseau
prenons ce qu'a dit Gérald Darmanin avec
l'écho terrorisme prenons Cyril Hanouna
qui se permet de traiter un député à la
vie de nul et même d'un tas de merde
pardon de de le citer dans le langage et
tout ça c'est pas que du buzz non Gérard
Miller ce que parlait veut dire ça va
au-delà du buzz mais sur votre plateau
même monsieur à l'instant vient dire que
Sandrine Rousseau le faisait rire ce qui
est relativement méprisant vous avez
parlé des absurdités de Sandrine
Rousseau donc voyez que la tolérance ce
n'est pas non plus absolument sur ce
plateau la règle ce qui ne me choque pas
mais reconnaissez que c'est pas
simplement les wokis ce qui serait
excessifs pour répondre ensuite à votre
question je trouve que vous avez raison
de parler du buzz et réseaux sociaux
mais qu'est-ce que vous venez de faire
là sinon de ramasser parce que je
connais justement un petit peu ce que
raconte son auto de ramasser en une ou
une formule ce qu'elle pense qui est
quand même un petit peu plus complexe
que ce qu'on vient de dire donc nous
sommes nous-mêmes dans nos débats
absolument oui mais Gérard est-ce que
vous considérez que le propos
quand elle compare
elle dit qu'elle préfère des sorcières à
des constructeurs de PR alors est-ce que
est-ce que ça me choque mais pas une
seconde est-ce que faire flamber le
patriarcat franchement est-ce que vous
acceptez puisque
les sorcières celles qu'on a appelé les
sorcières à travers l'histoire on sait
grosso modo c'était les emmerdeuses
celle qui empêchait de tourner en rond
et l'église et la médecine quand elle a
commencé à exister bien plus tard donc
effectivement il y a eu chez les
sorcières un certain nombre de femme qui
était des révoltés qui étaient des des
révolutionnaires avant l'heure et qu'on
a brûlé parce qu'elle cassait les pieds
à tout le monde et notamment aux hommes
donc elles viennent dans cette formule
rendre hommage à ces femmes par rapport
à ce qu'elle dénonce du côté du
nucléaire ça me semble en tout cas dans
une formule ramassée assez intéressante
et c'est vrai que vous avez comme moi
que c'est tout à fait utile de
réhabiliter l'essentiel pour un très
grand nombre et des femmes formidables
mais là je vous ai cité plusieurs
citations de vous vous rendez compte à
quel point déjà une des questions
le discours est en train de déraper même
si c'est pas que du
Buzzle
c'était que les petites phrases donc
c'est très bien que ce sont des
émissions qui sont reprises ensuite sur
les réseaux sociaux et que ça monte etc
qu'on est dans des algorithmes avec des
bulles
algorithmiques qui vont qui vous en fait
qui vous auto alimentent etc donc il y a
quand même ce fait là qu'on peut pas
négliger dans notre période après là où
je vous rejoins et ce qui me fait mal en
fait
c'est que d'un côté on est là pour
lutter pour l'égalité des droits les
inégalités et les minorités
et que ce sont des méthodes de
domination que vous avez dit c'est la
meute qui qui en fait créé cette forme
de terreur pour empêcher certaines
de la peinture sur des tableaux est-ce
que c'est une manière de défendre la
liberté
dans les années 80 il y avait aussi des
écologistes extrêmement violents moi ce
qui me fait de la peine aujourd'hui
c'est pas cette espèce de comédie du
spectacle etc c'est la
désindustrialisation du pays c'est le
fait que on a une guerre aux portes de
l'Europe c'est des problèmes
sont très importants mais nous notre
sujet mais notre sujet n'est pas là mais
en même temps tout ce que tout ce qu'on
dit sur le wokis fait un peu écran à
tous ces problèmes de fond il y a
peut-être aussi une perte de des bases
de la culture c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on
envisage de détruire des sublimes
tableau de monnaie de Van Gogh etc parce
qu'on est obsédé par l'idée que le monde
va donc peut-être 4 3 4 5 10 ans c'est
quand même quelque chose de si curieux
est-ce que nos établissements
d'enseignement secondaire primaire etc
mettent assez l'accent sur l'histoire de
l'art puisque vous voulez mettre là-bas
très haut intellectuellement mettons là
les croyances aujourd'hui et tout le
monde semble d'accord là-dessus
l'emporte sur les pensées rationnelles
autrement dit Cyril Hanouna
l'emporterait à l'applaudimette sur
Spinoza est-ce que vous y voyez un
danger pour la démocratie Gérard Miller
voilà une phrase à laquelle je souscris
entièrement surtout quand vous citez
Spinoza parce que je me permets de dire
que je suis de formation philosophique
j'étais professeur de philosophie avant
d'être professeur de psychanalyse donc
vous avez tout à fait raison et quand on
dit les croyances il faut étendre ça
bien au-delà de Cyril Hanouna et de tous
ceux dont nous avons parlé il faut
parler des religions peut-être wok
qu'avez-vous raison mais à ce moment-là
parlons aussi des religions des vrais
religions qu'on n'ose pas trop toucher
parce que à chaque fois il y a quelques
dangers non seulement à toucher
la religion l'islam mais même le
judaïsme le catholicide donc vous avez
raison c'est actuellement le triomphe de
l'extrême droite et le triomphe du
religieux ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord c'est qu'aujourd'hui on voit
effectivement à quel point croire est
devenu quelque chose qui remplace le
fait de penser et au Brésil quand même
ce n'est pas avec les télévangéliste au
brésiliens on en est pas encore
là mais vous avez raison de montrer
cette cette ligne de mire parce que
c'est aussi le télévangélisme américain
je je vois avec toujours sidération
comme nous acceptons que aux États-Unis
on prête serment sur la Bible vous avez
vu que pour la première fois
personnalité homosexuelle on nous dit
formidable la démocratie première chose
qu'elle fait c'est que Dieu bénisse
l'Amérique et compagnie donc oui nous
sommes actuellement menacés par les
croyances y compris les croyances
religieuses au sens strict au sens
strict et et de ce point de vue là je
suis sidéré de voir qu'on ne peut plus
aujourd'hui critiquer les religions sans
risquer cher donc vous consentez que le
débat porte sur une certaine gravité
bien entendu que vous critiquez au début
non je considère que le walkisme n'est
pas l'ennemi principal moi je crois que
vous avez le principaux et aux ennemis
secondaires je crois que n'est pas un
ennemi principal je crois que l'ennemi
principal c'est actuellement la droite
et l'extrême droite et mais au sens là
on en revient la responsabilité des
élites aujourd'hui pour s'exprimer avec
courage pour dire les choses pour
expliquer les la complexité des choses
et la psychanalyse peut peu aider
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là où la
philosophie c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
effort de pédagogie à faire qui n'est
pas toujours fait c'est vrai qu'avec
Cyril Hanouna c'est c'est le discours de
la rue qui entre dans les foyers c'est
effectivement pas le plus
le plus pédagogue il est certain qu'on
peut faire beaucoup mieux pour expliquer
le discours de la rue c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est effectivement insulté
de Bolloré et qui dit cette phrase qu'il
faudra marquer partout je ne crache pas
dans la main de celui qui me nourrit
c'est-à-dire qu'il est effectivement le
chien de garde de Bolloré je vous avais
vu la séquence il faut la regarder je
suis désolé dans la longueur c'est
fascinant c'est-à-dire ce député un
moment donné cherche pas du tout à faire
le buzz pour le coup sur Bolloré et
donne deux exemples notamment si Bolloré
et le chien de garde rugit à ce
moment-là arrive le mort le traitement
de tous les noms simplement parce que
son patron a été cité c'est d'une
indécence absolue j'aimerais un mot sur
la démocratie oui parce que on arrive
bientôt sur la démocratie
entre les différents dangers etc mais
notamment moi je reviens juste sur le
langage et le langage wok qui est pour
moi le début du séparatisme lorsque vous
commencez à dire que dans notre société
française vous avez des racisées et des
non racisés des afrodescendants des des
afro des je sais pas quoi quand vous
commencez à classer toutes les
catégories de personnes même s'il y a
des justement cette discrimination ces
discriminations pour lesquelles il
faudrait se battre main dans la main que
ce soit le motif ça a des conséquences
aussi pour faire un et notamment pour se
battre pour notre pays se battre entre
guillemets mais pour les questions
économiques pour les questions de guerre
qui approche et être en responsabilité
tous ensemble bien écoutez on va
conclure cette émission je vais vous
demander votre point de vue même si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur tous les sujets
évoqués vous êtes d'accord pour que la
démocratie reprenne le dessus mais alors
on se rend compte que cette démocratie
est contaminée par les affects par des
ressentiments etc à votre avis je sais
que la question est importante à défaut
d'enrayer cette pente que moi j'estime
totalitaire peut-être que vous partagez
pas cette chose là qu'est-ce qui qui est
en mesure et comment l'enrayer
je sais pas en tout cas ce que ce qui
est vrai c'est qu'il y a une montée de
du culte de l'émotion du sentiment de
l'expérience vécue vers juste la
rationalité l'argumentation etc c'est ça
qui me semble moi très inquiétant parce
qu'on peut très facilement manipuler des
foules sur ces questions de ce point de
vue là c'est effectivement la question
de la religion c'est à dire
qu'effectivement je suis lecteur de
compte qui expliquait qu'il y a pas de
société sans religion et où est le bec a
repris ça pour dire effectivement compte
avec compris qu'il y avait pas de souci
son religion si on est sans religion ce
qui est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui nous
sommes des particules élémentaires et
donc il y a une recherche effectivement
d'une religion à tout prix donc de ce
point de vue là je suis tout à fait
d'accord il y a plusieurs religions qui
se font concurrence je pense
heureusement ou malheureusement que la
religion ou autre n'est pas la plus
solide et il y en a d'autres qui
risquent fort de prendre le la place et
on voit très bien qu'il y a un espèce on
pouvait prendre un peu de recul et
regarder la géopolitique de ces
questions et on voit bien que ce sont
nos pays d'Occident fatigués démocratie
libérale qui se pose ce genre de
question et autour c'est au contraire un
argument qui est utilisé contre nous
voire Poutine voir si j'ai une ping voir
les dictatures diverses et et donc je
sais pas qu'est-ce qui peut nous nous
aider à nous en sortir mais ce serait
effectivement retour à la raison à
l'argumentation etc alors c'est facile à
dire bien sûr mais je pense que c'est le
travail de chacun dans son dans son
métier quand on est enseignant comme
nous etc d'essayer de refaire un retour
à la raison à la culture et l'histoire
de nos civilisation merci Jean-François
pour vous alors on a peu de temps mais
quand même très aider lieu de débat de
vrais lieux de débat vous avez parlé des
médias on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le
fait que les médias soient possédés à
90% par quelques milliardaires ça a des
effets quand même parti comme on nocif
pour l'organisation de débat et puis
j'ajouterai puisque nous sommes dans
cette noble maison de l'Assemblée
nationale que ce serait bien aussi
qu'elle Assemblée nationale on ne
considère pas que lorsqu'il y a du débat
c'est du temps perdu je suis désolé mais
moi je considère que le 49-3 utilisé à
tour de bras chaque fois qu'on le peut
pour éviter de prendre en compte le
débat lui-même c'est un mauvais exemple
donné à la société sur la valeur de
l'échange vous l'avez dit huberco Duriez
qui pourront rayer le débat aujourd'hui
il existe à l'Assemblée et dans les
médias qui est effectivement des groupes
de médias qui sont possédés par par des
oligarques mais mais il y a pas que ça
il y a aussi une presse de gauche qui
reste malgré tout encore assez vivace et
donc je pense que le problème de la
France aujourd'hui c'est d'accepter que
cette on parle de l'archipelisation
avant on parlait de la France une
manière un peu indifférenciée on
découvre que la France elle est
fragmentée que voilà tout le monde ne
pense pas de la même manière on donne la
parole à tout le monde et si finalement
assez sain pour la démocratie parce que
c'est ce qui lui permet sa réadaptation
dans le fond ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
se passer aux États-Unis dans les années
60-70 alors ça veut pas dire ça et
forcément dans le bon sens tout ça
c'est-à-dire que on est obligé de
s'éloigner un peu de l'idéal de l'idéal
social-démocrate de la de la de la
France surtout si
c'est principaux partisans tapent dessus
en permanence et et se comporte comme
des frondeurs qui en minent
progressivement les fonds
où il y a la plus grande redistribution
et il faudrait pas que on aide à mon
effondrement total une vigilance pour
nos plus jeunes peut-être de l'école
primaire à prendre ce que c'est que les
discours populistes et discours
propagandeurs les discours qui vous
empêchent de penser par vous-même qui
vous empêche la nuance la complexité et
puis dans ces réseaux sociaux dans ce
flot d'information on a peu de temps
pour notre intimité pour se retrouver
avec soi et savoir dans le discernement
quoi penser et je pense que les enfants
il faut leur apprendre déjà toi-même
qu'est-ce que tu penses au-delà du reste
merci ben écoutez on va rester sur ces
paroles alors je vais vous présenter une
bibliographie alors Jean-François
Bronstein vous avez publié la religion
vogue vous démontrez avec vos arguments
philosophiques que le vaucisme est une
religion vous restez sur cette semaine
la violence des réactions prouve bien
qu'il y a quelque chose qui est pas de
l'ordre de l'argumentation
très bien donc Rachel Kahn alors vous
aviez publié assez on en avait déjà
parlé mais depuis vous avez publié un
autre ouvrage
c'était un roman roman graphique pardon
un roman graphique sur les campagnes
électorales qui est avec les dessins de
Xavier Gorce une partie de campagne
voilà et qui parlait surtout en creux de
l'abstention
alors Hubert Coudurier j'ai pris votre
livre amour rupture et trahison vous
intéressez particulièrement à la vie
politique qui a été publiée chez Fayard
pour rester sur cette idée qu'en
politique il y a que des amours des
ruptures et des trahisons c'est à dire
que c'est surtout profondément apéritif
le point de bascule d'un président qui
dans le fond a évolué progressivement de
la droite vers la gauche qui se voulait
encore fédérateur qui estimait qu'il
fallait pas trop bousculer le pays un
président beaucoup plus finalement
trumpiste et qui parlait parfois à tort
et à travers mais en même temps avait
des intuitions fulgurantes parler de
quel président de Nicolas Sarkozy et qui
dans le fond dont la droite n'a pas
encore réussi à trouver des métiers bien
alors Gérard Miller je
vous avez peut-être publié un autre
ouvrage mais vous allez dire que je vous
ramène à Mélenchon mais vous restez
Mélenchon Mélenchon donc Mélenchon mais
oui et pas seulement on peut pas
seulement que sur cette chaîne le 12
décembre le prochain film que j'ai
réalisé sur Georges Marchais l'homme qui
avait choisi son camp sera diffusé ici
même le 12 décembre on prime time donc
qu'est-ce que vous en dites justement de
rappeler ce qu'est telle partie
communiste à une époque où le parti
socialiste était que dalle et de
rappeler à quel point dans les années 70
se partie a quand même fabriqué
l'élection de François Mitterrand et je
trace la vie d'ouvriers depuis sa
naissance de Georges Marchais décembre
avec nostalgie ou sans nostalgie avec
nostalgie que j'assume bien que en 68 je
me suis cogné à la fois contre les
fascistes les flics et les communistes
de l'époque mais je reconnais qu'il y a
quelque chose dans l'histoire du Parti
communiste qu'il ne faut pas oublier et
en mettant une distance avec Mélenchon
vous restez maintenant là c'est n'est
pas mon obsession donc il n'est pas du
tout très bien alors écoutez il me reste
à vous remercier merci d'avoir participé
à cette émission je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP et avant de nous quitter
je voudrais vous soumettre cette
citation je veux voir si vous trouvez de
qui elle est les mouvements totalitaires
sont des organisations
massives d'individus atomisés et isolé
vous avez une idée
oui Jean-François branstein dit
exactement bravo vous voyez le
philosophe nous a sauvé
[Musique]